well now it's time for a special treat  here on christmas eve did you know that  nate does uh  does traffic and weather but he also  does something extra i mean a lot of  people do know this we've seen nate  playing the flute he's been playing  since the fifth grade well i knew it  wasn't for me when i came in the door  this morning every once in a while he  breaks it out here on good day las vegas  nate what is on tap this morning sir all  right you guys we do have what we're  calling the special holiday edition of  flutie tutti friday  [Music]  so we are going to be playing something  appropriate for today  [Applause]  [Applause]  hey  so we wish you a merry christmas that is  your special flutie 2d holiday friday  now we are going to have a different  tune for you next week because i think  the song i'm going to play next hour is  a little bit more appropriate for me  when it comes to the holiday so you have  to stop and think about what that might  mean  i'm